so something else amazing happened last
night at Donald Trump's rally Donald
Trump compared himself to Abraham
Lincoln and not in just a general way
that Republicans have been trying to do
trying to rewrite history people like
Dinesh D'Souza trying to rewrite history
and make Republicans seem like they they
are the heroes throughout all of
American history no he did in a very
specific way comparing his eight
eight-year-old rather speaking level to
that of Abraham Lincoln's Gettysburg
Address take a look at the first clip
you know what Abraham Lincoln made the
Gettysburg Address speech the great
speech do you know he was ridiculed he
was ridiculed
he took the horse and carriage up from
the White House
he wrote it partially in that carriage
and partially at a desk in the Lincoln
Bedroom which is incredible by the way
in the White House and he went up to
Gettysburg and he delivered that speech
the Gettysburg Address and he was
excoriated by the factors that affect
you said he was excoriated
they said it was a terrible terrible
speech actually let's watch the rest of
the video and we'll take it from there
they said it was far too short it's not
long many of us know it by memory it was
far too short and it was far too flowery
it was too flowery four score and seven
years ago right to flowering and he died
fifty years after his death they said it
may have been the greatest speech ever
made in America
pretty good pretty good
have a feeling that's gonna happen with
us so here's the President of the United
States who legitimately speaks at the
eight-year-old level who can't pronounce
a four-syllable word anonymous who is
driven by his medley' mania his
narcissism and his sociopathy comparing
himself to one of the greatest icons in
American history who I'm sure is as we
dig into our action not sure I'm
confident that there are things in
Abraham's link Lincoln's legacy that are
up for debate but that's not what we're
discussing here the President of the
United States Donald Trump who is more
kin to our village idiot than anything
else
not only compares himself directly to
Abraham Lincoln but compares his
speeches to that of the Gettysburg
Address I don't really you know what
from the Washington Post jeet here he
said it best this is what he said on
Twitter he said quote this nation shall
give shall have a new birth of freedom
and that this government of the people
by the people for the people shall not
perish from the earth
Abraham Lincoln when you're a star
they let you do it you can do anything
grab them by the Donald Trump that's
what we're that's what we're dealing
with here
that's how ridiculous this assertion
this idea that Donald Trump is a
conservative he wrote on the level of
comparing him to the progressive hero
that Abraham Lincoln is or was rather
and so there there's another layer to
this that's worth discussing because it
is the revisionist history that
Republicans are engaging in and
conservatives are engaging in all across
the country Republicans are willing to
venerate Donald Trump to be sure and to
lift him above even Ronald Reagan
because Donald Trump in his his state of
being a blank
slade ideologically that's one thing
that you could pull from the article is
that Donald Trump doesn't really have
any convictions he's just in the
position and allowing the Conservatives
around him to do whatever they want
namely appointing so many conservatives
to the bench up and down the judiciary
and so because he's allowing this to
happen without any pushback in fact he's
enjoying it he's becoming he's
participating in it and because of that
conservatives are like yeah no Donald
Trump is one of the greatest presidents
in history never mind his level of
ignorance never mind his level of
narcissism
never mind hit the complete bereft of
morality never mind all of these things
that really relegate Donald Trump to the
dregs of society and to being lambasted
throughout history going forward
Republicans don't care about any of that
Donald Trump is just the useful [ __ ] to
carry out their hyper conservative
agenda which is generally focused on
cracking down on LGBTQ rights it's also
focused on cracking reinitiating the war
on drugs which has all types of racist
connotations to it and it's about taking
away a woman's right to have autonomy
and over her body and privacy in medical
decisions which is what Roe vs. Wade was
ultimately decided on but so long as
Donald Trump allows this to happen they
don't care about anything they will lift
him up in their revisionist history
above Ronald Reagan which Ronald Reagan
was not anyone to be heralded or trying
to try a champion but also above of
Abraham Lincoln I'm being infected by
Donald Trump stupidity there for a
second guys give me yeah but but that's
what they're willing to do and the one
glaring irony of this as they try to
maintain this mantou of being a part of
the original Republican Party and the
revisionist history that they're
participating in and they're prepared to
lift this [ __ ] Donald Trump unto into
the to the halls of American history
that rivals that of Abraham Lincoln the
biggest irony of this is is that the
Republican
party today is nothing like the
Republican Party of old it is
antithetical to the Republican Party of
old how do you know well the Republican
Abraham Lincoln waged a war against the
Confederacy and right now today the in
the South the south is owned by the
Republican Party the Confederate flag
waving south of the Republican Party
this is who they are and and all the
revisionist history attempts by people
like Dinesh D'Souza cannot erase the
fact that the racist southerners who
have their heritage in the original
Confederacy against which Abraham
Lincoln waged the civil war they are not
the party of Lincoln they are not the
party of of abolitionists they are the
party of southern segregationists and
slave owners that simply made their
shift once they realize that the
Republican Party was no longer a party
for them